notre invité politique ce matin c'est
emmanuelle wargon bonjour bonjour si
beaucoup d'être avec nous munissent
délégué chargé du logement on est
ensemble pendant 20 minutes quand une
interview en partenariat avec la presse
quotidienne régionale bonjour pascal
jalabert du groupe ebra les journaux
régionaux de l'est de la france on
commence évidemment emmanuelle wargon
par la crise sanitaire et olivier veyrat
qui a une nouvelle fois tiré la sonnette
d'alarmé hier soir il dit qu'une
nouvelle vague pourrait arriver d'ici la
fin juillet du ovarian delta due aussi à
la vaccination qui marque un peu le pas
léger ferrand qui demande aux français
d'aller se faire vacciner le
gouvernement qui répète que la
vaccination c'est le meilleur moyen de
lutter contre le virus est contre ce
variant du coup pourquoi attendre encore
pour rendre la vaccination obligatoire
pour les soignants puisque c'est la voix
qui semble être choisi par le
gouvernement
nous pensons que les soignants nous
avons besoin qu'ils soient vaccinés
est ce que disait olivier ferrand à
solidays hier je crois c'est que ça
n'est pas les montrer du doigt c'est
simplement leur demander d'aller au bout
de l'engagement qu'il porte pour leurs
patients et donc cette question de la
vaccination obligatoire des soignants va
être mise en débat y compris mise en
débat législatif puisque vous savez nous
sommes au sénat qu'il faut une loi pour
ça
en attendant l'important c'est d'avoir
le plus grand nombre de français
soignants et non soignants qui vont se
faire vacciner
mais s'il est là qu est ce qu il faut le
faire avant l'été vic si on écoute
olivier ferrand le temps presse il parle
lui mais la discussion elle va avoir
lieu dans les jours qui viennent vous
savez que le premier ministre a écrit à
toutes les forces politiques pour leur
demander une réponse d'ici demain il me
semble donc nous ne perdons aucun temps
une fois que nous aurons une réponse ça
permettra d'envisager un texte est
d'aller le plus vite possible en
respectant le fait qu'il y ait un
calendrier parlementaire et des
assemblées à faire délibérer messaouda
avant la paix et je crois
qu'effectivement l'idée c'est de le
faire vite
mais au delà de ça c'est de nouveau un
appel à la vaccination
toutes catégories de population
confondues nous avons les doses le
système de vaccination s'adapte le plus
possible maintenant il sera possible
d'avoir sa deuxième dose sur son lieu de
vacances et pas dans le même centre de
vaccination que là on a fait la première
dose c'est vraiment le meilleur moyen de
se protéger soi-même et de protéger les
autres et c'est tout le sud
j'ai de l'individu et du collectif on se
vaccine pour soi mais même si on n'est
pas inquiet pour soi même parce que
jeune parce que en bonne santé on se
vaccine pour les autres pour ne pas
propager le virus quand vous parlez des
soignants mais le premier ministre dit
pourquoi pas l'élargir à d'autres
catégories en contact avec le public ou
d'autres personnes
faut-il aller faudra-t-il peut-être
aller au delà des soignants puisqu'on
est très loin des 90 % de l'immunité à
l'heure et qui pour moi la question de
l'obligation c'est vraiment celle des
soignants ne serait ce que parce que des
soignants ont déjà des obligations de
vaccination vous savez que pour être
soignants ils vont être vaccinés contre
l'hépatite b donc pour moi la question
de l'obligation elle se concentre sur
les soignants mais quand on s'est
entendus hier françois bayrou qui est
votre allié 1 et qui dit j'ai toujours
pensé que ça finirait par la décision
collective de rendre la vaccination
obligatoire
est-ce qu'il n'a pas raison est ce que
vous n'êtes pas en train de reculer une
décision qui de toute manière sera
inéluctable c'est naturel d'avoir un
débat est d'avoir un débat politique sur
des choses fondamentales de ce type on
est passé de l'incitation à la
vaccination de la course pour avoir
suffisamment de doses pour pouvoir
proposer à tous ceux qui souhaitent se
faire vacciner
l'accès au vaccin maintenant cette
question est derrière nous c'est aussi
un exploit collectif
un exploit des laboratoires en exploit
scientifique en exploite organisation
maintenant on en est à la
sensibilisation et la question des
soignants peut-être qu'il y aura
plusieurs étapes
mais aujourd'hui pour l'après midi
françois bien méchant comment tout ça va
finir par ailleurs c'est difficile de
faire des projections à moyen terme sur
comment l'épidémie va se comporter
on va parler de la question des réformes
dans ce contexte vous êtes favorables
voient une réforme des retraites vous
l'avez dit vous disiez hier qu'elle
nécessite une forme de consensus
or ce consensus pour le moment il n'est
pas là vous entendez les organisations
syndicales
vous entendez la majorité des partis
politiques est ce que ça veut dire que
cette réforme elle ne se fera pas dans
les semaines dans les mois qui viennent
moi ce qui me frappe c'est aussi la
prise de conscience des français parce
que consensus à veut pas forcément dire
uniquement consensus avec les
organisations représentatives
ça veut aussi dire qu'est ce que pensent
les français et les français le savent
très bien qu'il va falloir rééquilibrer
notre régime de retraites et qu'à un
moment il
va falloir sortir du système dans lequel
on a toujours moins d'actifs qui
cotisent pour toujours plus de retraités
qui sont financés par notre système de
répartition donc pour moi le consensus
c'est une c'est une notion large qui
concerne évidemment les partis
politiques toutes les parties prenantes
mais aussi les français eux mêmes
et moi je pense que le pays en fait est
assez mûr pour ce sujet parce que il le
comprend très bien ne prendriez vous pas
un risque à réformer dès la rentrée
alors qu'on est en pleine relance si le
pays est bloqué est ce que vous n'avez
pas casser la dynamique
les premiers chiffres sont plutôt
corrects voilà si le pays est bloqué les
commerçants la consommation ont fait ça
en risque énorme
ce qui est sûr c'est que l'activité
économique se porte de nouveau bien la
relance fonctionnent et des derniers
chiffres de l'insee montrent que nous
aurons atteint nous aurons retrouvé
notre niveau de production et d'activité
d'avant crise à la fin de cette année ça
c'est vraiment très satisfaisant c'est
lié au plan de relance au plan
d'investissement après nous avons besoin
de continuer à adapter le pays aux
grands changements qui se prépare on a
parlé des retraites il ya évidemment les
questions de la dette publique et la
question de la solidarité entre les
générations et puis la question qui
m'anime qui est la question climatique
et sur tous ces sujets il ya une forme
d'urgence une forme d'urgence à agir
pour nous protéger pour nous protéger
des grands risques qui nous menace pour
nous adapter à l'évolution du monde
ceci doit pouvoir être fait dans le
calme dans l'apaisement dans
l'explication donc ya pas forcément
d'opposition entre transformer et
prendre des risques
on doit pouvoir y arriver en expliquant
en débattant ça a été un certain nombre
de sujets les ordonnances travail doit
être fait qu'on sait gérer phalange
sur les ordonnances travail tout le
monde nous avait dit quand les
ordonnances travail sont sortis vous
allez mettre le pays à feu et à sang
elles sont sorties les ordonnances
travail et finalement 1 le chômage
continue à baisser il a très peu monté
pendant la période de la crise et 2
finalement tout ceci a été accepté
donc ça dépend du débat ça dépend de
notre capacité à apporter ces sujets ça
dépend évidemment de l'évolution de
l'épidémie et après de toute façon la
question vous me posez elle est apposée
au président de la république puisque ce
sera son choix que vous avez bien un
avis sur la question d'autres l'ont
exprimé cet avis pour vous est ce que
cette réforme des retraites le débat
doit être engagée à la rentrée ou pas où
et pour moi il est un président qui est
passible d'engager le débat à la rentrée
et de créer cette forme de consensus
large juste un dernier mot là dessus et
bruno le maire hier il disait que les
effectifs avait une part de
responsabilité dans l'échec de la
précédente réforme en 2019
il disait notamment on n'a peut-être pas
bien su expliquer il y avait un manque
de lisibilité et la raison vous êtes
d'accord avec cela complique et je pense
que c'est une c'était pardon une réforme
extrêmement compliquée qui mélangeait
beaucoup de choses et qui en plus se
dérouler sur une période extrêmement
longue et on arrivait mal je le sais
parce que j'ai défendu cette réforme à
l'époque a expliqué simplement à vous à
moi ça va changer quoi ma pension
ressemblera à quoi donc peut-être qu'il
faut être sur un système un peu plus
restreint que c'était normes
refondations que nous avions envisagé et
que nous avions du mal à rendre
concrètes dont concrètement si c'est
restreint ça veut dire on se concentre
sur l'équilibré du système à savoir sur
les paramètres et on abandonne la grande
réforme
forcément on peut avoir des choses
intermédiaires et des questions
d'universalité à la question du minimum
vieillesse et des petites retraites donc
pas forcément mais on va pas faire le
débat avant le départ mais ça veut dire
qu'il faut pas faire la même réforme
pour vous c'est ça que dit la réforme à
l'identique je pense que ce serait
difficile de la reprendre à l'identique
on va parler de vos dossiers du dos et
des logements et notamment du logement
en outre-mer puisque on en parlait tout
à l'heure avec la sénatrice micheline
jacques de saint barthélemy puisqu'un
rapport qui a été rendu au sénat la
semaine dernière
assez alarmant sur l'état du logement
social en outre-mer plusieurs chiffres
déjà 80% des habitants d outre-mer sont
éligibles à un logement social
ils sont seulement 15% à habiter dans un
logement social il que 20% de logements
sociaux en outre-mer l'objectif de
construction de dix mille logements par
an n'a pas été attaqué ce que vous dites
face à ces chiffres
est ce qu'il ya une défaillance de la
part de l'état alors je suis globalement
assez en phase avec les conclusions du
rapport sénatorial et du coup je
voudrais saluer la mission puisque je
pense qu'elle a fait un travail
important en profondeur il se trouve que
j'étais à la réunion la semaine dernière
trois jours précisément pour prendre
connaissance vraiment de la situation du
logement à la réunion qui n'est pas la
situation du logement en outre-mer parce
que chaque outre-mer et spécifique mais
enfin c'est quand même significatif et
je partage les conclusions notamment sur
un point qui est la territorialisation
parce que ça m'a beaucoup frappé nous
avons un plan logement outre-mer qui est
partagé entre le ministère des outre-mer
et le ministère du logement qui est en
fait un cadre général qui pose des
grandes lignes mais ce cadre ne suffit
pas il faut vraiment que territoire par
territoire il ya eu une interprétation
collective de ce que ça veut dire et la
création d'une vraie feuille de route
opérationnelle pourrait plus concrète à
la réunion ce qui manque c'est des
petits logements très sociaux
c'est pas tous les segments du logement
social ce sont les logements sociaux qui
coûte le moins cher
les logements très sociaux parce que le
prix du logement est très chère à la
réunion et les logements de petite
surface parce qu'il ya moins de grandes
familles parce qu'il ya des personnes
âgées isolées qui commence à avoir
besoin d'un logement parce qu'il ya des
personnes qui sont actuellement dans des
structures d'hébergement ou à la rue qui
n'arrive pas à voir avec ces relogements
fabra pour plein de raisons
une fois qu'on a dit ça ça veut dire
qu'il faut se donner ça comme objectif
opérationnel à la réunion plutôt
produire ce type de logements sociaux
il ya vingt-quatre communes est la
réunion donc la négociation elle peut
quasiment se faire commune par commune
pour savoir comment est ce que tout ça
ça s'organise donc le l'ancrage beaucoup
plus opérationnelles de ce plan est
nécessaire
moi j'en suis revenu avec la conclusion
que au moins pour la réunion c'est
principalement une question de moyens
d'état ne serait ce que parce que la nba
ligne budgétaire qui porte les crédits
budgétaires du logement outre-mer a été
ré abondé à la réunion l'année dernière
et que par ailleurs elle est pas
toujours consommé à l'échelle est
capable dans cette ligne budgétaire elle
a baissé dans l'ensemble les passé de
270 millions il y a dix ans à 220
millions aujourd'hui est ce qu avait
trait à bond est juste mais moi je suis
absolument convaincu que quand on a des
projets on sait les financer et concerts
et abondé bien sûr les crédits
d'hébergement d'urgence qui sont les
crédits de mon ministère france entière
quand on a des besoins supplémentaires
ont négocié avec bercy et on trouve des
solutions pourrait abonder bref vous
êtes hors à mettre plus si les
outre-mers vous le droit je suis prête à
mettre plus avec sébastien lecornu bien
sûr puisque c'est lui qui est
responsable de cette ligne budgétaire
mais je suis prête à me battre avec lui
pour avoir des crédits supplémentaires
mais je ne suis pas sûr que ce soit
principalement une question de crédits
d'état
c'est une question de capacité à fédérer
pour que des projets sortent de terre et
puis à la réunion ce qui était très
frappant c'est qu'il ya beaucoup de
projets validés donc de construction de
logements sociaux sur lesquels il ya eu
un accord de tout le monde la mairie le
bailleur social l'état qui a dit ok je
finance et trois ans après ça a pas
commencé et n'a pas commencé parce que
bas le permis a pas été délivré parce
qu'il ya une difficulté parce que les
entreprises en les appels d'offres ont
été infructueux enfin pour plein de
raisons techniques
justement que j'ai juste la traîne pour
finir sur la territorialisation puisque
vous nous dites oui je suis d'accord
avec le sénat il faut une
territorialisation est ce que pour que
ça aille plus vite vous allez porter
cette question dès la loi de
décentralisation qui arrive au sénat
mercredi
je ne crois pas qu'on soit prêt pour la
loi de décentralisation qui arrive dans
trois jours puis par ailleurs c'est un
travail encore une fois à faire avec le
ministère des outre-mer je vois mon
collègue la semaine prochaine pour en
parler mais ensuite on n'a pas forcément
besoin d'un texte législatif le simple
fait de dire on se on se donne quelques
lignes directrices très très
opérationnelle pour les deux années qui
viennent territoire par territoire avec
des indicateurs plus précis on les suit
peut-être que ça suffit qu'on n'a pas
besoin d'un chantier législatif
important
comment vous expliquez que des français
on va dire entre liam et aisée pour
cette les logements des logements
rohmer et sont poussés à investir à
notre mère moyens la défiscalisation que
ça ne produisent pas d'effets sur place
alors il y a quand même un parc privé et
qui est financée voilà par ces outils de
défiscalisation de français d outre-mer
ou ou de la métropole il faut vérifier
que ce parc répond aux besoins vraiment
et ça fait partie de ce travail de
territorialisation kit ajusté après pour
que la défiscalisation incita de la
production qui soit vraiment utile
et puis après on a une deuxième
difficulté en outre-mer que j'ai mieux
compris en allant sur place qui est la
détérioration rapide du parc parce que
pour des raisons météo climatique etc et
aussi parce qu'on n'a pas forcément
construit comme on construirait
aujourd'hui on a des bâtiments qui sont
pas si vieux 20 ans 30 ans et qu'il faut
complètement réhabilité et qu'on a deux
sur lesquels on a financé la
construction à un moment et maintenant
il va falloir financer la rénovation
donc ça pose aussi des questions sur
quelle construction
il ya aussi le problème des logements
vacants il ya beaucoup de logements
vacants dans les outre-mer dans la loi
égalité réelle pour les outre-mer en
il ya une taxe sur les logements vacants
qui a été voté sauf qu'elle n'est pas
appliquée est ce que vous allez faire en
sorte qu'elle soit appliquée cette
valeur j'ai été interpellé par les
parlementaires
là bas j'ai interpellé on a eu cette
discussion puisque j'ai évidemment eu un
échange avec eux et je me suis engagé à
regarder exactement donc je suis rentré
vendredi donc j'ai pas encore la réponse
est aujourd'hui mais on va regarder vous
allez réfléchir il ya une autre demande
des sénateurs s'est d assises d assises
du logement dans les outre-mer est ce
que ça vous êtes prêtes à les organiser
ces assises
pour moi ça va avec la
territorialisation parce que je suis pas
sûr qu'il faille faire une grande
démarche générale sur les outre-mer pour
moi chaque territoire ou ultramarins à
ses propres besoins et donc cette idée
de territorialisation et de feuille de
route moi j'ai souhaité que le préfet
produisent un projet de feuille de route
et le partage dans une réunion formelle
très collective à la rentrée avec tous
les acteurs parce que ça n'a pas de sens
d'avoir une feuille de route et à il
faut avoir une feuille de route pour le
territoire de la réunion donc avec la
présidente du conseil régional au
président du conseil départemental les
maires les bailleurs etc on va parler
d'eux
loi sru la loi solidarité renouvellement
urbain c'est la loi qui impose des
quotas de logements sociaux aux communes
cette fois elle expire en 2025
vous avez dit que vous allez travailler
sur cette question dans la loi
décentralisation qui arrive mercredi au
sénat concrètement qu'est ce qui va se
passer à ce que vous allez la prolonger
encore où est ce que cette loi va
devenir pérenne alors ça c'est près
puisque ça arrive et ça sera discuté
d'ici la fin de la semaine en première
lecture au sénat
nous rendons facile sénat le vote nous
rendrons la loi sru permanente c'est à
dire que tant qu'une commune n'a pas
atteint 20 ou 25 % de logements sociaux
la mécanique de la loi sru continuent
mais nous la contractualisant beaucoup
plus et donc je crois que nous avons
trouvé un point d'équilibré entre une
obligation que nous réaffirmons et le
fait que les trajectoires pour atteindre
cette obligation seront plus souples et
plus contractualiser aux bons ingénieurs
et dans les airs maires et préfets
très concrètement la loi sru dit vous
devriez avoir tant de logements sociaux
dans telle commune
vous n'y êtes pas donc vous devez
rattraper l'écart
il ya une formule de calcul pour
rattraper l'écart et plus on se
rapproche de la date limite qui est 2025
plus la formule de calcul est dure et
elle n'est pas négociable
demain l'écart de base à rattraper par
période de trois ans ce sera un tiers
mais ce sera modulable c'est à dire si
une commune dit moi je peux pas
rattraper un tiers de mon écart en trois
ans c'est trop difficile
on pourra réduire à un quart voire
réduire encore plus si on est dans une
démarche intercommunale
donc il ya une marge de négociation ce
qui veut dire qu'il ya une marge de
grisant comme une commune par commune
entre le préfet et le maire une marche
de prise en compte de la réalité
on retravaille aussi les exemptions dans
un certain nombre de cas des communes
demandent à être exemptés pour
différentes raisons donc on réécrit un
peu la base des exemptions pour qu'elle
soit plus adapté à la réalité et donc
l'obligation reste et je pense que c'est
important on a besoin de logements
sociaux partout et notamment on a besoin
de bien répartir le logement social sur
le territoire mais avec des facultés des
assouplissements une capacité à tenir
compte de la réelle
et et qui sera plus forte qu'aujourd'hui
où les outils actuels le permettent mais
justement y at il vraiment besoin du
logement social partout ne faut-il pas
plutôt mener une politique hyper
décentralisée hyper localiser on sait
très bien qu'il ya des communes qui en
veulent pas qu'ils n'ont pas un client
de te fait qu'ils n'ont pas la
population pour ça donc pourquoi une loi
qui contraignent tout le monde d'accord
en fait le logement social c'est
potentiellement le logement des classes
moyennes parce que vous disiez que en
outre-mer 80 % des ménages sont
éligibles au logement social en
métropole ça doit être 65 ou 70 %
logement social c'est pas la
représentation des logements de mauvaise
qualité dans des grands ensembles et ses
rivaux deux cas le logement social
aujourd'hui ce sont des petits immeubles
le logement social aujourd'hui ce sont
une partie de programme immobilier quand
vous regardez un programme neuf qui se
construit parfois c'est impossible et
c'est très bien de dire quelle est la
tranche en logement social et qu'elle
est la tranche qui ne l'est pas donc le
logement social c'est juste du logement
à prix régulés pour les classes moyennes
y compris ce qu'on appelle les
travailleurs clé les infirmières les
aides soignantes les caissières et c'est
à tous ces gens qui ont besoin d'habiter
pas trop loin de là où ils travaillent
et on s'est rendu compte pendant le
premier confinement à quel point ces
travailleurs étaient essentiels à notre
vie collective
donc la loi sru l'imposent du logement
social
en gros dans les grandes villes dans les
villes moyennes dans les métropoles là
où il ya de l'activité économique est là
où il ya besoin d'avoir des personnes
qui travaillent et qui n'ont pas à faire
une heure et demie de transport aller et
retour pour aller travailler
donc le besoin il existe partout après
il ya beaucoup de formes de logement
social il n'y a pas de raison de
stigmatiser le logement social
donc je suis convaincu qu'il faut garder
cette obligation
c'est grâce à cette obligation qu'on en
a construit la loi sru elle date de 2000
on a construit 1,8 million de logements
sociaux depuis dont la moitié dans des
communes soumises à cette obligation
sinon on concentre et la concentration
cpv des communes qui ont 40 % de
logements sociaux alors que justement ce
à ceux à ce sujet on voudrait vous faire
lire ce que disait hier olivier
capitanio vous êtes élu vous du val de
marne c'est le nouveau président du
conseil je les supplie conseil régional
a au titre du val de marne mais pas de
vol avait été tête de liste dans le val
d'hérens le nouveau président du conseil
départemental il dit justement que il
veut changer la politique de logement
etc l'une de ses premières décisions
sera d'arrêter de financer la
construction de logements sociaux dans
les villes qui en compte déjà plus de 40
% et de réaffecter ces crédits aux
communes car en c est ce qu il a raison
alors moi la partie de la phrase qui
m'intéresse le plus c'est la
réaffectation comme une carence et parce
que j'ai eu beaucoup de discussions avec
les maires du val de marne j'en ai
d'ailleurs eu avec les maires du val
d'oise et maire des yvelines et en
dehors de la région ile de france j'ai
reçu physiquement ou par visio beaucoup
de délégations de mer pour bien
comprendre et un certain nombre de ces
mères disent on n'est pas contre le
logement social simplement parfois c'est
difficile on sait pas très bien comment
boucler les opérations on a beaucoup de
contraintes
donc moi la partie qui m'intéresse dans
ce qu'il dit c'est on va aider les
communes carences et à développer des
programmes de logements sociaux parce
que dans certains cas on est plutôt dans
une situation de blocage
après ils ont appelé la réaffectation
nadia et nous avons signé une lettre au
préfet il ya quelques semaines pour leur
dire d'arrêter de financer des
programmes de logements très sociaux
dans les communes qui sont je crois
qu'on avait dit au dessus de 35 %
donc moi je ne suis pas contre un arrêt
systématique parce que dans le logement
social vous avez des logements étudiants
vous avez des résidences vieillesse vous
avez des logements intermédiaires et
beaucoup de types de logements n'y a pas
de raison d'avoir une règle en dur mais
en gros dire quand on a déjà 35 ou 40 %
de logements sociaux dans ce cas là on
fait attention à la diversification sur
n'en produit plus très bien et pour vous
c'est 35 ou 40 parce que valérie
pécresse par exemple dans le parisien
vendredi est là disait qu'ils font un
plafond à 30% mais les logements ce
sujet valérie pécresse elle a divisé par
plus de deux le budget du logement et du
logement social à la région ile de
france dans sa dernière mandature
elle est passée de 100 millions à 40
millions donc elle parle surtout son
bouclier mais en réalité ce qu'elle a
fait c'est qu'elle a désarmé la
possibilité de la région de financer des
plans de
en trente pour tout le sujet ce n'est
pas tant le plafond qui est un sujet
très symbolique qui va toucher très peu
de communes que la capacité à faire là
où il ya besoin alors juste question
politique déterminée emmanuel macron
pascal oui donc le président un
maquereau et puis son entourage ont
constaté quand même l'échec aux
dernières régionales font-ils
restructurer le parti républicain marche
ou alors qu'on me dit françois bayrou
créer un grand mouvement différend
pourrait au mandat éventuelles d'abord
on a besoin de plus d'ancrage local
c'est clairement ça qu'on ressent parce
que il ya un côté poule et l'oeuf dans
ces élections pour pouvoir être crédible
vis-à-vis des électeurs il faut que les
électeurs vous connaissent vous
reconnaissent vous ai vu à l'oeuvre y
compris dans des fonctions d'opposition
et ce sont nos militants qui avait été
candidat aux élections municipales qui
sont candidats au départemental qui
progressivement créé cet ancrage et du
coup nous avons besoin à la république
en marche un territoire de progrès dont
je fais partie d'avoir des militants qui
sont vraiment sur le terrain
le fait de faire une campagne
dématérialisée ça n'a pas aidé non plus
puisque pendant toute une période
c'était difficile elle à la rencontre
des électeurs
après nous avons un socle politique et
un programme politique un projet
politique qui est large
en gros aux valeurs républicaines de
droite modérée et de gauche modérée et
il faut que les partis qui porte sa pour
le président trouve la manière de le
faire de façon unifiée et fluide alors
est-ce qu'il faut un grand parti
plusieurs des sensibilités ça tout ça ça
va se discuter
et vous dans les différentes
sensibilités vous parler de territoires
de progrès moi je fais du rallye temps
le progrès c'est un peu la lgo chante
absolument capturer delà de la majorité
il y aura un congrès ce week-end vous
êtes candidat pour la tête de nouriture
tracé pour prendre des responsabilités
dans territoire de progrès je suis il
est intéressé par la présidence le
congrès de ce week-end c'est juste un
congrès statutaire qui définit les
statuts donc chaque chose en son temps
en tout cas je suis intéressé pour m'y
investir et y prendre des
responsabilités
c'est vraiment ma famille politique
c'est celle à laquelle je crois c'est
celle qui est bien représentée par le
président de la république et par son
bilan social et qui n'est représentée
par aucune autre force politique parce
que le ps est là
représente plus et c'est assez entendre
cette aile gauche vous avez l'impression
en effet on essaye mais voilà chaque
fois plus cher parent c'est pas
forcément qu'est ce qui est sûr c'est
que le bilan social du président il
n'est pas suffisamment connus et défendu
il existe moi je considère que le bilan
social du président est meilleur que le
bilan social de la mandature hollande
merci vous remercie manuel wargon
d'avoir été notre invité merci pascal
[Musique]